Hey, what's up guys I’m out here with Devin Graham, aka, Devin Supertramp aka make her exceptional quality digital content
And you have any idea what we're doing here today
We are going to make something awesome, and it's gonna be random and I'm doing it with the king of random
So that's what I'm guessing my hypothesis. He has no idea what we're doing today. No idea. What's making it up?
We are making super shooters these things are pocket slingshots powered by [balloons]
You don't really want to use anything harder than a marshmallow because as innocent as the
se look it does pack quite a punch and can do A lot of damage so [a] big marshmallow little one. Yeah a little tiny marshmallows, so you can hit me from here to here
Yeah, I can get you there. Oh
I love my life flash before my eyes. Let's do this [oh]
Good look that's the t-shirt that [is] stuck to your shirt. Wait. Let me hit you again. Yeah, sweet, and I like this guy [oh]
Yeah
No, I'm definitely hurt. Let's see it. See that guy's that is from a marshmallow
Marshmallows will leave welts, okay. I'm a second dog poop. Oh
Grant is stepping in dog poop to make this work. All you're gonna
Need is some kind of a juice bottle drink bottle soda bottle whatever what we're looking for is one of these wide mouths cap
so if you go down to the store
You're gonna see a huge variety of different caps
You'll see white caps black cabs purple caps yellow caps red caps pretty much anything you want so I tend to lean toward black caps
They work really well pretty much with any color of [balloons], so I'm using the powerade. Oh, dude. Where'd it go?
We just [lost] a bottle I'll dive in ahead. Are you gonna try? I don't know if you can see it. Maybe grab
This is like poop infested duck pond. So you
Wow
I don't think we're gonna be drinking that all about the shop though, all right
I [check] this out guys so depending on the size of pocket slingshot
You want look at the tops of the bottles you can see gatorade is a little bit bigger than the powerade and the power it
Is more than normal size of what you're going to find on juice containers and everything else
so if you want a bigger slingshot gatorades the way to go this is not a sponsored video second contact exact go
And this guy actually won. I wasn't even close okay. It's time to cut the tops off the bottles choose your weapon
I'm Gonna go with [the] saw okay
He's Gonna take a saw
We'll try out the [sooners] and let's see what the difference is
You see how it kind of slopes in there's a gap
And [then] there's that flat part of the neck if we want to cut it so it's exactly flat
I'm not a good cutter. Should you be doing this? What's the worst that could happen?
Success, I didn't screw it up
We have the capitated bottle and you can see how this is nice and flat that [is] exactly what we want right there
But it's a little bit dirty. We need to clean it up and for that
We could use just the natural environment around us
Maybe some concrete or if you happen [to] have some maybe a little sandpaper will go a long way bring it everywhere I go
So just follow along you learn how to sandpaper with me. That's kind of what we're known for on our channel
While Devin's working on that I'm going to show you how you can do with a pair of scissors. This is not recommended
This is actually very dangerous, but it will work
I just wanted to show you that it will work, so get your bottle on a flat surface
punch into it like so and
[man] that's really hard plastic this will actually work better on one of those bottles like the Gatorade or powerade
Bottles, but it will work
with a pair [of] scissors as you can see
So just get it roughed off, and you can see it's going to leave quite a bit around the edges there
But that's not a big deal you [can] take your scissors and kind of do another pass and clean it up. Oh
shoot
Mine's a little bit sticky, so I'm just gonna wash it off there to clean it up a bit
But essentially that's what it's gonna. Look like and unfortunately with a pair of scissors
That's about as good as it's gonna get hey guys good. Wow, how did yours turn out Gonna? I'm gonna turn that awesome
Do that service it's actually mine is like super smooth the question is can I get it out?
And I guess I can so we're about to put the balloons on we got a bag of balloons
You can grab [bagg] from the dollar store or your party supply store
So Devon's going with the black and red I'm going with kind of this Goldish orange and a black cap
That's [gonna] be cool. But before you put your balloon on the cap. There's a black band on here that needs to come off first
This can be tricky yeah, yeah, don't cut it. Do not cut you not cut it we want that band
We want to preserve so just dig your fingernails down [in] there
And take a success
Definitely guys [all] [right]. So now that we got our caps prepared
We've got our balloons picked out the next thing to do is to modify them and we're gonna come up about a quarter to [half]
Inch up the neck of the balloon and just slice it
Make a clean cut well that's actually pretty terrible job, but I've seen better excuse me. I'm not gonna Lie. I've seen better
Whoa like a Doc
[try] [to] see if this does it oh
beautiful flawless
Okay, teamwork that is what it's supposed to look like just take your [cap] with the cut part them on the top
I guess we're just [gonna] [open] that balloon up wrap it around so that the top edge of the balloon is
Pretty much exactly flush with the top of that bottle top. I've got wrinkles in mine, so I'm just gonna work those back
[we] want to get rid [of] all those wrinkles. Okay? I think I got a really good actually [okay] cool
So now look at the balloon and see how well centered it is when it holds up on its own
Great. That's like a pretty good [debit]. I'm impressed. Thanks all right now remember that little black band
Yes, replace the little black band so now after our black band is back in place if you take your thumb
And just gently roll it back. You can see it's going to roll that rubber back
And it's actually gonna fit right into that groove of that bottle thread. It makes it look super clean super professional
Here's the trick you just take your thumb
[and] just kind of glided around and then it all
In there and see how it's kind of like a rounded Ridge which gives a little more bulk
So now when you pull the balloon. It's not going to pop through because that [rim] holds it in place check it out guys
We are finished Devin's got his red pocket shooter. I got my orange pocket shooter
You can see if you look straight [down] the balloon is pretty much centered mine's a little off, but it's not bad though
Yeah
now I have to do is hold it with your thumb and finger and
you can even nestle it in there in the webbing of your thumb, and then pull it straight back and then
Shoot it
Now when you're done using the slingshot this is the coolest thing you can wrap this up put a little bit of ammunition in there
And then you can actually screw the cap back on and it makes this little
Compact puck that fits perfectly down into your pocket. No one will know that you have a concealed weapon on you
So it's super portable. It's very inconspicuous, and it's just a lot of fun. There's the cat stuff
I wish I had when I was in Grade school
[not] that I'm saying that you should take these to grade school times have changed
I just had a random thought I wonder if we could use this thing to shoot marshmallows out for the duck Steve
I'm not talking about shooting the actual ducks. I mean I like trying to hit them no no shooting marshmallows for them to eat
Brilliant
[oh], I took the bait if you were to look down through the center of this thing you'd want to see it snap exactly through
that hole [in]
Contrast if you're off a little bit it might snap up and hit your finger or snap down and hit your hand you don't want
That so it is Gonna
Take a little bit of practice to work on your Aim
If you're a little bit nervous about hitting your hand you could hold it just between your thumb and your finger
Try that way as well. It's just a little bit harder to hang on to [alright] guys
So just for contrast we're gonna do a [gatorade] bottle. [there's] no bad ideas here, but there's definitely no good ideas here
Sorry, I'm not doing [a] very good job. Oh
[it's] like the best one we've done yet not too bad
[and] then we've got like a wider mouth [does] [a] [team] [work] so [grantees] pulled out like 30 of these out of his back pocket
No, big hail, so now we got some money. What should we do with them battle?
Any last words. I think you're Gonna Miss I
Could tell because you have glasses on your eyes are protected, so [I] say we just do one no
That's straight on no, no
No
You know I got like seven in here. We're going shotgun effect. Oh
Did he leave welts oh?
Oh good [good] shot. That was good shot. It was kind of cheap shot
It was I had no bullets
And he shot me [when] I had nothing to fire about this is I had one stuck in there
I just wanted to like get it out there for sure ah
Nice nailed it nailed [Devin] awesome. I am surprised. How far these things are flinging now look at that
I think it's not as hot maybe yeah the sun's gone down so marshmallows will work
You just got to get the right conditions to see you walking [back] check that out. Huh watch the bushes. What's it?
See that it's amazing. [that's] a marshmallow. So what we have learned though
Is it definitely does get things way too sticky if you start screwing around [now] these things may seem fairly innocent
But they do pack a real wallop. So [we've] got a few little rocks here, and the bottle blasters from a previous project
We're going to see if it's powerful enough to make these targets explode. They really do sonic booms yeah
Okay, Devin's up
Yet is she like super good
and one job oh
That one is the bottle you need a sharper one and hit a little bit harder
[I] saw my life flash before my eyes I
Didn't get out loud so with this little contraption
We shoot a well with a 20 ounce bottle maybe a little bit bigger about this day well 500 milliliters
And we're talking like pieces for days like well fit into the week
So we're gonna spend the next two or three hours cleaning up this mess that we made when this stuff is everywhere and like
That's not normal took me a while to use of the marshmallow rocks
Though are like guaranteed fatal so like I'm stoked on [this] so to take this up a notch. We're using sidewalk chalk
We're going to crush this down and go powder to give our exploding targets a little more color [a] [little] more zest if you will
I think we got a winner
There we go. [I] don't think we want to go much more than that
Okay, update guys, so we got [a] huge [exploding] target filled with chalk dust behind [it] we each have one rock
We're gonna shoot these at the same time and see we get this first try. Yeah alright here. We [go] guys for the win
three two one
First try you got that right [I]?
Wasn't close was I?
Actually, I was one the nails [hey], you'll never know
So what's the deal with the salt?
So I use this salt for killing flies
You can use these those fly shooters like in the house or enzo and [yarn], just pour a bunch of it
That's probably enough
You don't need a whole lot, but this acts kind of like is a shotgun effect
So if you get a fly on the wall or [on] your computer or something shoot a little salt at it
So kill kill fly it'll knock it on a commission. Yeah
Whoa, it's pretty good actually legit. Yeah. It's like a shotgun effects everywhere
You gots alright here if you want to give her the flies in your backyard or your house
You got marshmallows which are all over the place?
They're tasty and the good thing about these is they don't hurt [people] too bad as long as you get them in the stomach
They will be welt it will leave looks more dangerous options Airsoft BB's will work these will punch through cardboard
And then of course steel BB's these are probably like the real no no these will do big damage
Do not shoot at people or property or any living thing don't shoot ducks or children?
So before we let you get out of here devon. There's something everybody wants [to] know what [do] you look like with your hat off?
The world will never know. Oh come on pick it up pick it up yes. Yes. Yes
Being naked oh the devon grammars ville you saw it here first folks out here first Grant Thomas [Ed] live uncut unedited
Unrated if you want a team [supertramp] hat you can go to the devin supertramp [web] [site] if you want
But it's not really our thing [okay] guys. Thanks for hanging with us today
it's so cool to make these slingshots with you and to be hanging with the
Supertramp himself me and Grant are kind of unique because we're not so much the face of our channel grad
Please more than I am but we kind of go full-on out with our production, so I'm glad we got to do something together
[yeah], this is really fun, [and] I hope you enjoyed it as well
and
You guys have been asking for projects that are really easy to make and very cheap to make I hope this solves that need for
You go out blast these around the world have fun
Have a great time go make something and we'll see in the next video. Talk to you then
Hey guys, just wanted to give credit where Credit's due. This is David Peterson
He does a lot of music for the devin supertramp
Channel recently I've been using a lot of his music on my channel as well, and you can too
You could use my songs and you could submit songs to grant over it use my songs comm slash the king of random so go
Check out his website use my songs calm and show some love
you